مجددا في الصوره مع اقتراب حفل تتويج
الملك تشارلز المقرر في السادس من مايو
المقبل قبل اسبوعين من اصدار الدعوات
البريطانيه والمنقسمون حول تواجد دوق وذوق
في الحفل مع تصاعد سوى التراث مع العائله
المالكه خلال الاشهر الماضيه استطلاع رايي
اجرته ميل اون لاين وجد ان سبعه واربعين
في المئه من البريطانيين يؤيدون دعوه قصر
بوكينغه
بينما يرفض 36% حضورهما لكن معهد الابحاث
رد فيلدا
38% يريدون مشاهده هاري في الحدث في مقابل
36% يرفضون حضوره اما بالنسبه لميغن
فالنسبه الاكبر ترفض حضورها في مقابل
33% فقط يؤيدون تواجدها في الحفل
بجانبي هاري وميجين كان هناك بعض الاسماء
الجدليه التي طفت على السطح قبل نحو شهرين
من حفل التتويج الامير اندرو شقيق الملك
والمجرد من القابه الملكيه يرفض الخروج من
قصره في لانه لن يكون قادرا على تحمل
التكاليف السياره عند قطع المنحه السنويه
له في ابريل المقبل ويلوحه بكتابه مذكرات
على خطب شقيقه بحسب بعض التقارير
البريطانيه تقارير اخرى تبرز رفضا محتملا
لحضور الحفل من قبل بعض النجوم هل تنجون
مثلا الذي كان مقربا من ديانا وحتى ادى في
مراسم جنازتها في عام
1997 سيكون من الغريب ان يغني امام زوجها
السابق وعقيلته كامله طبعا
احد اهم الفنانين في بريطانيا ملتزم
بجولته الغنائيه في امريكا الشماليه ويوم
التتويج من المقرر ان يكون في تكساس اخيرا
النجم العالميه اديل من المحتمل ان ترفض
الحضور ايضا في حفلها الاخير فيس قالت
انها تعاني من الام الظهر المزمنه ولا
تملك اي ارتباطات فنيه في جدولها بعد
الخامس والعشرين من مارس
[موسيقى]
محمد استاذ محمد يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا
في صباح العربيه دائما طيب بين من يحضر
ويحرم من الحضور الى الحفل ما هي اخر
التفاصيل حفل التتويج الملك
صباح سهام ونادين والمشاهدين الكرام يعني
جميعا نترقب وصول الدعوات طبعا حوالي
الفين دعوه متوقع وصولها وانا من بين
الناس يعني ممكن احلم ان تصلني دعوه لحفل
التتويش فلم احضر حفلا مماثلا السابق ولكن
طبعا الجدل يزداد في الاوساط البريطانيه
عن من سيحضر مثل كل المناسبات العائليه
وان كانت هذه مناسبه عائليه ملكيه بامتياز
لكن الخلافات تطفو من جديد على السطح ولكن
ايضا
المسامحه ومساله ماذا سيقول الناس ماذا
سيقول الراي العام هل ندعو هذا الشخص الذي
اساء الينا خلال العام وكشف في مذكراته
قصص غريبه عجيبه عن
ما يجري وراء يعني اسوار القصور الملكيه
الاغلب النهري وميجان سيتم دعوه
من وجهه النظر القصور الملكيه اي اخبار
يتم تداولها اخبار مفيده لماركه الملكيه
المسجله البريطانيه من ناحيه من ناحيه
تانيه هناك ايضا الملك تشارلز الذي هو
يعني لا اعتقد انه يود ان يجلس على كرسي
التتويج من دون على الاقل ابنائه ولديه
اثنان يعني
وعائلتهما بغض النظر عن المشاكل وهذه
القضايا هناك ايضا الاعراق والتقاليد ان
تحضب اعضاء الاسره وان يكونوا في صفوف
الاماميه للحضور في مثل هذه المناسبه
الملكيه التي يعني لا تتكرر عاده بالنسبه
يعني للملك وبالتالي هذه هي الفرصه وهي
ربما تكسر الجليد الذي نشا وساده العلاقه
بين
الشقيقين ويليام وهاري بين القصر الملكي
والابن الضال هاري وزوجته ميغان في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بشكل او باخر
هي الفرصه الثمينه التي اعتقد ان الملك
تشارلز وايضا الراي العام البريطاني قد
يكونان يعني اقرب الى مساله الافضل دعوته
طيب صحيفه التلغراف كذلك استاذ محمد قالت
انه من الصعب ان لا يحضر هاري في اليوم
التاريخي بالنسبه لوالده لكن في المقابل
الى اي مدى سيكون حضور الصعب لمواجهه
البريطانيين بعد ان اثار غضبهم خصوصا بعد
مذكراته الاخيره
يعني بشكل او باخر اعتقد ان البريطانيين
متسامحين متسامحون عاده مع مثل هذه
القضايا والامير هاري يعني كان يحظى
بشعبيه كبيره وان تراجعت الى انه يعني
اذا قصناها على انفسنا في النهايه هو ابن
هذه الدوله هو الامير الشاب المغمور الذي
لطالما عشقه المواطنون وبالتالي ربما يعني
نصف المواطنين او نصف المستطلعين قالوا
يعني يودون دعوه ورؤيه هاري في المناسبه
واعتقد ان ايضا الملك تشارلز سيكون على
راس المطالبين او من من يعني يقولون
بدعوته وفق الاعراف والاسس الرسميه في
البلاط الملكي وبالتالي يعني ربما تطوى
صفحه وتفتح صفحه جديده مع هاري هذا ما
يريده الراي العام البريطاني ربما طيب
استاذ محمد هل يستغل او قد يستغل هاري
وزوجته ميجان احتياج الملك تشارلز
والمقربون لحضور حفل التتويج للحصول على
امتيازات كانوا قد فقدوها خلال العامين
الماضيين ام انهم اصلا لا يريدون هذه
الامتيازات
اعتقد نادين المشكله الاساسيه هي اصرار
هاري على ان يحظى على اعتذار ما عن
التصرفات التي
بدرت عن بعض افراد العائله الملكيه هو
اخوه والده ربما تجاه زوجته
من اصول افريقيا سوداء وبالتالي هذا ما
يود ان يسمعه هاري ولكن لا اعتقد انه ذلك
سيتحقق من الان حتى ذلك الحين اما عن
مساله الامتيازات اعتقد ان هري وميجان قد
تناقد حسناء امريهما وخرجا من هذه المؤسسه
مؤسسه الحكم والبدلات الملكيه البدلات
الاميريه
الى ذلك قد تم قطعها منذ ذلك الوقت منذ
يعني يعني ازاله الالقاب الملكيه عنهم
وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان هذا الامر مطروح ما
يطرحه ماجن وهري هو اعاده يعني اعتبارهما
اعاده الاعتبار الى شخصيهما من خلال
اعتذار ما
انهما انه قد تم ظلمهما من قبل بعض افراد
الاسره وهو ما تتمسك الاسره بشكل او باخر
او قصر الملكي بالصمت حياله
ليس من المعتاد ان يكون هناك مثل هذا
الامر ربما يتم الاعتذار في بشكل سري او
بشكل يعني داخلي بدون خروج ذلك الى
الاعلام ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه ليس هناك
بوادر لمثل هذا وعلى فكره استاذ محمد
دايما الحديث ممتع جدا معك واحنا بنشكرك
جزيل الشكر من لندن الصحفي محمد شباره
شكرا لك